The Conjuring series of movies has been
going for a full decade now and it's
been a runaway success since pretty much
the start but what about quality which
of the eight movies are blessed and
which ones are demonically bad the 2014
Conjuring prequel Annabelle made a
respectable 257 million dollars
worldwide but reactions to the film were
far from kind one look at the movies
Rotten Tomato scores shows that film
goers and critics alike weren't pleased
with the possessed dolls Antics based on
the Annabelle doll first seen in The
Conjuring this spin-off focuses on a
couple welcoming their first child the
doll terrorizes these new parents and
seems intent on taking their daughter's
soul but it turns out that it's the mom
sold the demon is after what sets
Annabelle apart from other entries in
The Conjuring universe is just how stale
and uneventful the overall film feels
outside of some shots of the doll
looking intimidating or being positioned
ominously in a room there isn't really
much to keep audiences on the edge of
their seats
a doll
we need to get rid of it
not only is the film's antagonist aboard
the human characters also lack
personality plus the ending in which the
movie's only black character sacrifices
herself to save the white protagonist
led to some serious criticism the
concept of a killer doll isn't exactly
new and with so many better entries into
the genre to choose from Annabelle is
completely forgettable also just to note
despite the priest from Annabelle
appearing in the curse of La Llorona the
latter movie's director clarified that
it isn't actually part of The Conjuring
Series so it isn't on our list
the nun boasts some haunting Gothic set
design and striking period costumes the
film might be the most visually
interesting entry in The Conjuring
franchise however some pretty production
design isn't enough to make a film
function and it's safe to say viewers
weren't impressed with this entry
overall it's set in 1952 and features a
group of nuns living in a Romanian Abbey
they discovered that World War II bombs
have reopened a spiritual Rift that once
was sealed to keep demons from entering
into the world the film follows a Nova
[__] who is determined to find the root
of the evil emanating from the monastery
and banish a spirit called valak that
has taken the form of an undead nun in
the end the movie looks nice but is
packed with one note characters lazy
dialogue and forgettable jump scares the
nun manages to feel completely flat and
devoid of creative substance despite
having some stylistic Flair
The Conjuring the devil made me do it
follows paranormal investigators Ed and
Lorraine Warren as they try to save a
young man named Arnie who accidentally
invited a demon into his body during an
exorcism on his younger brother whatever
happened
that day
set in 1981 the third Conjuring movie
takes the Warrens on a convoluted
Journey that involves dangerous totems
and a curse rooted in the occult in
their efforts to help Arnie the Warrens
learned that there is much more lurking
beneath the surface of this possession
they also helped make history by
supporting Arnie in a landmark trial
after he kills his landlord this element
of the story is based on the real-life
murder trial of Arne Johnson in which
the Warrens were involved
I think it's about time to accept the
existence of the devil
while the devil made me do it isn't the
worst movie in the franchise it also
isn't the best it UPS the ante
particularly for Lorraine but it relies
too heavily on tired jump scares the
demon is one of the least impactful in
the series as well
if you thought you'd Seen the Last of
valik you were wrong the nun too picks
up four years after the events of the
first nun following Sister Irene in
Italy she now leads a simpler life after
her last encounter with the demon
however that piece is interrupted when
she's asked to investigate some unusual
deaths taking place across the continent
if there's something here
that's not meant to be
what follows is a story that gives more
insight into the demon that includes
missing eyes killing the descendants of
the saint that took them and a delivery
boy turned puppet as Sister Irene Dives
further into history in her attempts to
send valik back to hell for good she
also learns more about her own ancestry
and the power of a mother's love the nun
too is a sequel that improves on the
mistakes of its predecessor valik is
given real motives this time around
rather than just being a scary presence
and one of the other nuns is given a
subplot that's actually culturally
relevant while the movie is ultimately
an improvement over the first and is
better than recent films in the universe
it's still a middle of the road entry
in this third Annabelle film Ed and
Lorraine Warren come into possession of
the cursed Annabelle doll the couple
safely locked the possessed plaything
away in their occult Museum protected by
a glass case and shielded from the
outside world it looks like all is well
it's safer for these things to be in
here than out there
sometimes it's better to keep the genie
in the bottle
of course one slip up is all it takes
for Annabelle to cause Havoc when the
Warren's daughter Judy is left in the
care of teenage babysitter Mary Ellen
the haunted doll seizes on the
opportunity shortly after Mary Ellen
arrives her friend Daniela makes an
unplanned visit Daniella is hoping to
reconnect with her deceased father so
she trespasses into the Warrens locked
artifact room and accidentally releases
Annabelle a beacon for other Spirits
Annabelle sets free a slew of spooky
entities from the couple's collection of
cursed objects turning the once peaceful
Warren home into a demonic House of
Horrors you would think a cast of wacky
demons running wild would result in some
creative scares and there are a few but
most of the film is just a slow build up
for one jump scare after another none of
the demons really get enough Focus to
make them stand out from the more
interesting cast of Unholy Spirits from
previous films
The Conjuring 2 is one of the best
received entries in the series but it
nonetheless feels a little like the
creative teen tried and failed to
recapture lightning in a bottle with
this sequel in the end The Conjuring 2
feels like it was made with the
intention of setting up an expanded
universe instead of telling a complete
self-contained story especially
considering the spin-offs that followed
soon afterward
aside from the crowded roster of spirits
the primary demon gives its name to
Lorraine in the beginning of the movie
which is the key to defeating it in the
end it makes the resolution feel not
only rushed but unearned despite these
gripes The Conjuring 2 is still a worthy
successor to the first film making use
of interesting camera work slow
build-ups and the sort of creepy imagery
that fans of the franchise have come to
expect
a prequel to The First Annabelle film
Annabelle creation shows the origin of
the Demonic doll the film opens with a
couple witnessing the death of their
young daughter Annabelle nicknamed B The
Grieving parents are willing to make any
bargain just to spend more time with her
and when a spirit begins making itself
known in their house they think they may
have gotten their wish but B isn't the
same upon her return and they soon
realize that they've invited a demon to
reside in their daughter's doll
so we locked it away
where it could be surrounded by the word
of God
to repent for their actions the couple
takes in a group of girls from a
recently closed orphanage unfortunately
for them Annabelle wants to play the
cast of child actors does a good job and
there's some decent writing to support
them as well there are some genuinely
terrifying visuals that help drive home
the sadistic nature of the demon there
is a unique balance in Annabelle
creation between highlighting the
emotional punishment endured by the
people in the house and the physical
punishment doled out by the sadistic
Spirit letting the two complement each
other and build an anxiety-inducing ways
what are you guys well we've been called
Ghost Hunters paranormal researchers we
prefer to be known simply as Ed and
Lorraine Warren critics and fans agree
the first entry in the franchise is also
the best instead of being thrown into
the Paranormal with little explanation
the characters are forced to do research
set up and monitor equipment and work
with local police just to get enough
proof to have an exorcism approved as a
result of all the added legwork not only
does The Conjuring feel more believable
and accessible for audiences but the
frightening payoffs feel earned the
chief marker of this film's quality is
the building of atmosphere this is
demonstrated particularly well through
how reserved and understated some of the
scares are the musical score is allowed
to be soft and to serve as a background
to scares instead of the blaring bass
heavy blasts in later movies the minimal
CGI used throughout the film is also
done with Precision demonstrating the
common adage particularly true in horror
that less is more
thank you